this is a production of cornell
university
so good morning everyone and welcome to
our webinar on success with laser
scarecrows i'm julie kickert with
cornell cooperative extension
and we're i'm on a regional vegetable
program in the western part of the state
we call ourselves the cornell vegetable
program
i want to just so i have my
co-hosts and presenters
uh rebecca nelson brown and david h
brown
on the line from the university of rhode
island and they will both be presenting
about the scarecrow that they've
developed and tested
and then
one of my collaborators chuck bourne
who's also with cornell cooperative
extension in the eastern part of the
state of new york the eastern new york
commercial horticulture program
so we welcome both of them
i do want to acknowledge the funding
sources that have made development of
the laser scarecrow possible and also
testing
so
currently we have a
specialty crop multi-state
block grant program that rebecca brown
is the lead pi on it comes from the
univer the usda agriculture marketing
service
uh
chuck and myself and marion zuffle from
the new york state ipm program have a
new york farm viability grant
allowing us to help also do some of the
work and rebecca and david brown and
others have had pass funding from the
rhode island farm viability
specialty crop block grant
and
sustainable agriculture research and
education
projects
so
um
i guess i was the one that kind of
dreamed up this uh this webinar
oops sorry i think i uh
advanced that without wanting to do that
and so what what are we trying to do
here i think our learning objectives are
one to provide a background on laser
scarecrows so dr rebecca brown is going
to do that
we have people on here who don't know
anything about the laser scarecrows if
curious for the first time
and we have some folks that have tested
the university of rhode island or other
scarecrows on their farm previously
rebecca has experience with
definitely sweet corn
and some grapes and small fruits
and i know we have some other folks who
are on there who might be interested in
tree fruits or other things so i think
you'll be interested at least to hear
the general background and if you're not
interested in continuing
with the more
probably specific discussion
that focuses a lot around sweet corn
which is our primary crop you're welcome
to leave at any time i'm not going to be
offended
or anything but
after the general background we're going
to give an overview of the university of
rhode island laser scarecrow device
and the improvements that have been
planned for 2022
and how to get hooked up for getting a
kit for those
devices
and then throughout this
both in rebecca and david's
presentations
we want to really help growers
understand how to set up and adjust the
devices in their on their farm so that
they have success
so
we did some
had some test lasers out chuck and i did
last year and grower field
there were also growers throughout
the northeast and some other regions
that
purchased devices
kits put them together and then put them
out in their own field so we had a
kind of a wrap up webinar back in early
november
talking more about the research and
had some of the growers on
talking about their devices
and so a number of people have
had success with the devices
i was picking up on and concerned about
the number of growers that said they
really didn't have success
i came in on this project last year
and
it was a huge learning curve for me
about how to set up the devices how to
adjust them and whatnot
and i think i'm really set up for good
success this year
but um
we i personally learned a lot we learned
a lot that uh
you know informed
what improvements needed about the
devices and so our goal really is
anybody that's interested is to try to
right from the start this is what you
need for success
we are going to be around
all season
as resource folks and we want this to
work for you if this is the right thing
for your farm
so
we chuck and i are going to give some
tips from our programs we would like any
of the growers that tested to also chime
in and give some some tips and then we
hope to have a good period for question
and answers but we do need to end by
10 30.
so um that's that's kind of my part
and um hopefully now we've got everybody
in on board and ready to go
and i'm going to stop sharing my screen
and invite dr rebecca brown to share
what she has
and
we'll get started with her presentation
so rebecca if you could share
okay good morning everyone
um hopefully you can see my screen now
and
i can see that yes yes okay
um so i am going to start things off
this morning um with just a general
introduction
to laser scarecrows
um
and then i will hand the microphone over
to david who will talk more specifically
about
the mechanics and the engineering and
things like that
so
laser scarecrows are very much
designed to work against birds
um
they take advantage of the fact that
birds rely on sight to detect threat
people often ask about using laser
scarecrows against deer
and they don't work as well against deer
because deer don't rely on sight as
their primary threat detection sets
birds have really good eyesight it
varies from species to species of course
but in general
birds eyesight is ten times better than
humans
both their ability to see colors and
their ability to sense motion
it's said that pigeons
can see the stars move
and they can also
see
things that are moving much faster than
we can make them out
um
birds of course especially flocking
birds find a certain amount of safety in
numbers
and one of the things that this means is
that if you have a stationary visual
deterrent such as
a tube man or a windmill or something
like that
the effect radius is going to be fairly
small
because
the birds are willing to take the chance
that
there might be an attack because there's
so many of them you know odds are that
it'll be somebody else who gets caught
they're also very intelligent and birds
are able to quickly identify and ignore
things like scary eye balloons and
effigies
as well as startling noises this is one
reason why
propane cannons have a limited
effectiveness is that just like we tune
out a constant background noise
the birds will start to tune it out
so the challenge
given all of this
is how do we repel birds from a large
area without physically traversing the
area and you could
hire someone to drive around your corn
fields all day with an atv and i've
heard of farmers doing that
but of course that gets very expensive
and it requires that
you give up land for the atv to drive on
so that it's not crushing the crop
and this is a problem not only in
agriculture it's also a problem in
situations such as airfields where you
don't necessarily want someone
rushing around the airfield all the time
with you know in a vehicle
but you need to keep the birds
away from the planes that are taking off
or landing
so the solution to this
which was actually come up with quite a
while ago
was to use light
and in particular highly focused light
which is what we call lasers
the advantage of light
is
that it can
reach a very long distance and of course
it doesn't
um
pose any sort of physical resistance so
it can move
right past things right through a
cropped canopy without causing any
injury
for this reason lasers have been
investigated for bird control since
really the early days of laser
technology the first researchers working
on this were in the 1970s
those researchers at the time
were limited by the state of the laser
technology in those days
they were using gas lasers which were
very fragile and also required an
extremely large amount of power
and that limited their use they also
didn't really in those days have any way
to automate the lasers
since then
improvements in both laser diode
technology and battery technology have
removed most of these limitations
and you're probably all familiar with
handheld laser pointers
which take advantage of both of these
in the 1990s
we started seeing lasers adopted by
airports and industrial sites primarily
in europe
these were mostly hand-held human
operated units they often look like
large flashlights
they have a greatly expanded beam and
they're
powered by batteries
there were also some stationary
automated units that would turn on in
response to stimuli but didn't move
with these units the emphasis was on
covering large areas so the beam ranges
were up to
um
8 000 feet or more and these handheld
devices are very much still on the
market
the limitation with them
is of course that you have to have a
human operator at all times
and so that makes the most useful for
situations such as airports
where
the um
risk of monetary
damage from a bird strike incident is so
much greater than the cost of having an
employee
you know patrolling
with a handheld laser that it makes
financial sense
since 2010
there have been further improvements
both in laser technology but even more
importantly in
microcomputer technology and in solar
panel photovoltaic panel
technology
that have made solar
autonomous laser scarecrows possible
and reasonably affordable
unfortunately
lasers
since they do pose a risk of harm
both
harm to eyesight and
for higher power lasers a risk of burns
or starting fires
lasers are very strictly regulated
and a lot of the regulations around
lasers are quite old
and so it creates a very complex
regulatory environment
and this has discouraged
commercialization
of
mid-range models so right now if you
look um
at the commercial landscape you have
very low power models
designed for consumer use
and then you have
expensive high-end models that have very
elaborate
um safety
programming and things like that
now early research with lasers through
the 90s and the early part of this
century assumed that lasers would only
be effective under low light conditions
and so most of the studies
targeted roosting birds in the evening
and
most of these studies were not very
effective at moving birds away from
their roosting sites
they could disturb the birds but
oftentimes the birds would come back
and certainly once they stopped treating
the roosting site
with
a laser the birds would come back
however more recent studies including
our work
has focused on daytime use targeting
feeding
birds and has been much more successful
particularly when the laser
is automated and able to operate
continuously
during the daytime
so this is just a clip taken at
late dusk
that shows you what the laser beam looks
like as it moves through a
cornfield and i just want to note that i
have slowed this down to one quarter of
its actual speed so that you can see it
um one advantage of the laser is that it
can cover an area pretty quickly
so as you saw in that um
you know the beam is basically moving
through the tassels on the corn
we can only see the laser beam
in low light conditions like this but
the birds because they have so much
better eyesight than we do can see the
laser
even when the sun is shining
so i just want to talk a little bit
about some of the questions that we
frequently get asked
um first of all why are birds scared of
lasers we don't actually know
because of course we can't get into the
mind of the bird
but people who study bird behavior
have suggested that birds may perceive
the beam as a solid object
and so they move
in order to avoid that object
and it is true that in corn what we have
seen is that the primary effectiveness
of the laser
is that it stops the birds from perching
on the tassels
which they usually do before they move
down into the canopy
to feed also
by stopping perching on the tassels
it will
cause the birds that are keeping watch
for all of their flock mates
to move and that will result in the
entire flock moving
many people ask if birds become
acclimated to the lasers this is a
really good question because of course
that is the failure of most bird scare
technology
is that the birds become acclimated to
it over time
and we have some colleagues at the
university of florida
who have
been testing
exactly this question
using captive
european starlings in an outdoor aviary
and what they have found
is that the birds do not appear to
become acclimated to the lasers
and they may actually become more
sensitive more afraid of the laser with
repeated exposure
this study is ongoing we have one season
worth of data at this point and are
going to start a second season within
about a month
so hopefully
by later this year we'll have
an even more conclusive answer to this
but it does appear
that birds do not become acclimated to
the lasers
another question we often get is what
birds are controlled by lasers and
obviously
not every species of bird has been
tested
in general lasers seem to work best on
birds that flock together rather than
moving about
as individuals or just a few of them
there have been research studies that
have successfully used lasers on geese
cormorants gulls blackbirds robins cedar
wax swings
starlings and cowbirds
and there are other studies
currently underway
you know lots of different species are
being
controlled using lasers
so i want to talk just a little bit
about um using lasers specifically in
different crops
so
for any crop
you need to start laser protection
before the birds begin feeding in the
crop
with sweet corn this means
starting before the corn is mature
before the birds begin moving into the
field
and checking the corn out
in sweet corn you want to mount the
laser at tassel height
with the beam horizontal and this field
this clip that julie was kind enough to
share with me
shows you
um
where it should be positioned you can
see she has the laser right in there
with the corn
and you can see the beam moving across
the green shield
showing that it's basically projecting
horizontally out over the field
um if your corn field is sloped you want
to put the scarecrow at the top of the
slope
and basically project the beam at an
angle down the slope so again it's
hitting
the tops of the tassels
the uri laser scarecrow has been
designed
so that the beam cannot be projected
more than five degrees above the
horizontal
and this is because
one of the risks of using lasers
is that if you're projecting a laser up
over the horizon into the sky
there's the possibility
of it shining through the windows
of an aircraft
that is
taking off or descending towards landing
and causing flash blindness of pilots
using a laser to interfere
with aircraft operation is illegal in
the united states um it will get you
into big trouble with the faa
and so
since many of the uri units are being
used in perry urban areas where they're
within 20 mile radius of an airport
we designed the units to make
projecting the beam up into the sky
impossible
um that said i know there are situations
such as fruit orchards where you may
want to project the beam at an angle
above the horizontal
and some of the commercial units can do
that but you have to be very careful
when you're doing that to make sure
that you're not impacting
air traffic
with
plants that are of varying heights you
want to use the ability of the laser to
move back and forth on the vertical axis
to hit all of the tassels
if you've got a
crop
that say it's it's two different
planting blocks side by side and one is
shorter than the other
you need to make sure that you put the
laser scarecrow on the side
with the shorter plants
so that they're not being shaded
from the beam by the taller plants
because
remember that laser beams travel only in
line of sight
if you can't see something you can't hit
it with a laser beam
and birds will
sneak in under the beam if it's going
over the tops of the tassels
um they they'll just basically treat it
like a roof and duck in under that roof
and get into the canopy to cause damage
now as julie said most of our research
has actually been with sweet corn that
is what all of our grant funding has
focused on but we have done a little bit
of research on other crops we are
constantly seeking funding to do
research on
more crops
um and we have learned a little bit
about using lasers in crops other than
sweet corn
um one thing we've learned is that for
short crops whether it's seedling corn
that you're trying to protect from geese
and crows
or turf grass sod that you're trying to
protect from winter feeding by geese or
strawberries
any short crop
you actually want to mount the scarecrow
as high as practical you can see down
here
this is a commercial unit that
unfortunately is no longer available in
the us that we were testing
on a kentucky bluegrass sod farm and
we've got it mounted on top of a
traveling irrigation rig about 15 feet
off the ground
um and then you aim the beam down
and what you want to do is
set the vertical movement of the laser
so that you're sweeping the crop
from the base of the scarecrow to the
edge of the field
again you need to be careful with a
short crop that the beam doesn't go into
a roadway or a neighbor's windows
that you keep it to your field
but that does seem to be the most
effective way
to try and keep particularly geese out
of fields
for blueberries on the other hand you
want to mount the scarecrow about three
feet or one meter above the canopy
and then move the beam
through the entire vertical range of
motion as well as horizontally
so that you're covering as many
different points in the canopy as
possible
what little we've learned about using
laser scarecrows in grapes it seems like
the approach you take is going to depend
on your training system
if all of
the clusters are basically at the same
level then you can treat grapes like
corn
and use the laser to create a virtual
lid over the field
but if the clusters are at all different
heights
then probably it needs to be dealt with
more like blueberries
where you're moving the beam through
many different places in the canopy
okay i want to close here
just by mentioning
sources of laser scarecrows
um there is currently only um
one real source of
um commercial
lasers that are designed for use in
agriculture and
other serious
outdoor bird control settings
and that is the avix autonomic from bird
control group these are sold all over
the world
um
the company itself is in the netherlands
and then they have a north american
office out in oregon
it is a commercial product from a
full-service company they will even come
and install your unit for you they
provide
on-site tech support a lot of different
things
these are 500 milliwatt lasers that can
cover very large areas depending on the
crop they a single unit can cover as
much as 100 acres
and they are designed to operate 24
hours a day year round
even in the winter with extremely low
temperatures
but of course
this is all going to cost you and the
list price of these units is about ten
thousand dollars
um so they're they're a good
unit but they're a very high-end unit
um
up next david is going to talk about the
uri laser scare pro which is the one
that we've been using in all of our
research
this is an
experimental
unit it's an open source
unit the design is available on our
website
we use 50 milliwatt lasers and we're
only able to cover up to nine acres but
we are deliberately targeting
the um
grower with smaller fields or with um
fields with lots of different
elevations
where you're not going to get the
economy of scale
that justifies using the larger
lasers our units will not operate at
night or at temperatures under 40
degrees fahrenheit so they're not
currently a good option if you're trying
to keep geese off of fields in the
winter
but they are available as a kit
for
650. there is only a limited number of
these kits because we aren't actually a
commercial
enterprise
and unfortunately for those of you
tuning in from canada
the complexity of shipping lasers across
international borders means that we're
only able to offer the kits in the u.s
we also
will not do on-site tech support
we do offer tech support via email or
phone but again
it's not like we have a large staff of
people who can come out to your farm
and help you set the thing up and
operate it
we that said we are actively looking for
someone or multiple someone's interested
in commercializing
the uri laser scarecrow or a design
based on our unit
there definitely seems to be a market
for a smaller
unit
that is able to sell at a significantly
lower list price
than the avix autonomic
so that's what i have i will open it up
to questions
uh thanks rebecca so i'd invite folks to
uh either put their questions in the
chat or unmute i think we'll just take a
few minutes here before we transition to
david
i have one question rebecca that i
thought about that someone asked me here
recently and that is
does the laser beam
hurt the eyes of the birds
that is a really good question julie
and it is a question
that many people have asked
and the answer to that is that actually
we don't know yet
um
dr esteban fernandez jurissic at purdue
university is actively working on this
question
he has found
that
if you shine a laser beam
a high power laser being directly into
the eye
of an immobilized bird it will in fact
damage the bird's eye this is not
all that surprising
however what we haven't been able to
determine yet because of limitations on
funding
is what the chances are
in
a real world situation where the birds
are moving around foraging free to fly
away or turn their heads
that a bird will actually take a direct
hit
to the eye from a laser beam
this is an area of active research and
an area that we're hoping to get some
answers to over the next few years if we
can get the funding unfortunately
um
detecting damage to birds eyes requires
um euthanizing the birds and then doing
a
pathological examination of the eye
and that is extremely expensive to do
so this really limits our ability to do
these studies
okay rebecca we've got a couple comments
in the question
uh the chat box so the first one
says hi we have been using the scarecrow
for a couple seasons here we haven't had
much luck
especially with crows has anyone noticed
crows being deterred
um that's a good question i have not
tested the lasers against crows we don't
have a big crow problem at the research
farm
they should work against crows but again
it really depends on um
whether you get the laser out there
before the crows find the corn
um and also probably on the flock size
and crows are pretty brave
and if there's only a small number of
them
they may
not be startled enough by the laser
okay rebecca that um
just reminds me of something we were
talking about uh
a couple days ago in preparation for
this meeting and that had to do with
crows in a
in an urban setting that that roast
roost on trees and whatnot
and maybe you could just address that
real quickly
right so there have actually been
studies done out in davis california
looking at using handheld lasers
to try and eliminate
crow roosts from urban areas
and what they found was that
the lasers were effective
at removing the crows from the roost if
the trees were treated
um right at dusk as the crows were
coming in to the roost
but that treatment
the effectiveness of the treatment
stopped if they stopped treating the
trees
so it would probably work
but in an urban setting
it would probably mean using a handheld
bird control laser and sending
a human operator out
every evening
to treat the trees as the birds were
coming into roost
the in an urban setting you have to be
really careful with an automated laser
because of course there are a lot of
people around and thus a lot of risk
um
that someone could be
impacted by the laser beam and
potentially suffer eye damage
so this is where you would want a human
operator
okay great we've got uh let's see if we
can work through some of these other
messages so the next one said you
mentioned a nine acre coverage
but do we know what the effective
distance of the beam from the scarecrow
and lineal feet and so i know that is
something we are still
trying to get to uh trying to get more
data on but do you have any other
comments on that rebecca well
basically that at present um we're
pretty comfortable saying that
a 300 foot radius would be protected by
our units
um
but yes this is something that we're
still trying to actually determine what
the maximum um
distance is and it does of course
depend on the terrain and also on the
crop um
in that
if you're projecting the laser down onto
something like
um
seedling corn
you can get a much larger radius than if
you're projecting horizontally
you know depending on the height i was
getting as much as 600 foot radius on
the unit mounted on the irrigation
system
but that was also a flat field and
the unit was 15 feet above the ground
okay great
hey rebecca yeah along along these lines
of a nine acre coverage area um because
you know we're you are designing these
units for
kind of multi multi plantable acres in
terms of yes you know we don't have one
planting usually in in one field so if
you had three or four different
plantings you know all coming in within
a week of each other
in one field
where would you recommend someone place
the laser would you put it in the middle
of the field would you put it
kind of like between two plantings and
then as soon as they're done start
moving it over to the the later
plantings
do you have any any thoughts on that um
well so it depends on a number of things
first of all
um
it would depend on
the
differences in plant height among the
varieties
if you've got
say
a um
you know a really early short variety
and then the next one to mature is a
taller variety
you would want to put it put the
scarecrow
on the
side towards the shorter variety
and then projecting into the taller
variety
because otherwise you're not going to be
able to protect both
you also of course have to take into
consideration things like roads
you don't want to be projecting the beam
towards a roadway
um
but
yeah i mean you certainly can put it in
the middle of the field if
that
is going to get you know that would give
you the widest coverage
um as long as you don't have too much
variation in plant height and you don't
have something such as a road that's
going to cause a problem
did that answer your question chuck
thank you yes all right
so i think that um
there's a lot of chat going on and david
and chuck have been helping answer some
of that and i think some of those
questions will be answered as we move on
um
one and i know this was a a question i
had wanted to raise was about safety
in the field
when you have workers out in the field
and whatnot and i think david sort of
adjusted
answered the question in the chat box
that
you know we would recommend turning that
laser off while you had workers in the
field but
uh do you have any other comments on
that rebecca before we move on
yeah um just that these are class 3b
lasers and so um
the regulations do require eye
protection um if people are working
inside the hazard distance
so if you're not turning the lasers off
when um
you have workers in the field
ideally they should have laser safety
glasses that they're wearing
there is no risk of burning but if you
stare directly into one of these beams
you could have
retinal damage
and
certainly repeated eye exposure over
time
is going to cause things like cataracts
and other
cumulative damage
so you don't want to look directly into
the beam
that said these beams
if the
is operating normally
are constantly moving and so that
combined with your blink reflex
really lowers the likelihood of actually
getting a beam directly in the eye for
long enough to cause damage
but still it's best to err on the side
of safety
okay great um
so somebody said what is the hazard
distance
um
we haven't actually measured it and i
would have to look it up for these
specific
lasers
um i don't know if dave remembers off
the top of his head what it is for these
yeah we did calculate this um near the
end of the season
we realized that was an omission from
the initial user manual and based on the
output power beam diameter and
divergence using the ansi
z136.1 calculation
we came up with a nominal ocular hazard
distance of 16 meters or 53 feet
so when you're outside that range
you should not be adversely affected
even if you did
happen to look at the beam within that
range
i would suggest you keep your head down
and walk over to the switch and turn it
off
so
all right so that sounds good i think
that uh it's time to uh for rebecca to
stop sharing her screen and then david
or if that's what what you're doing and
then david could get set up um
about his there was uh for his
presentation rebecca real quickly there
was another question about if you had
tested the lasers
in sweet cherry orchards at all
we have not tested them in sweet cherry
orchards
that would be
a very intriguing study to do we don't
have any sweet
cherry orchards in rhode island
um i know that there have been reports
of lasers being used in sweet cherry
orchards um i think it was in british
columbia
but again this is a fairly new um
technology in terms of being used in
agriculture and so there's lots of
studies that haven't been done yet
okay
ah thank you we do have uh some
cherry orchards here in new york
especially below the lake in uh
lowell lake ontario so i know one of our
fruit specialists is on so if you ever
want to test them or they do
yes this is what we can do i'd be
interested in testing i could probably
find a cooperator to test it in sweet
cherry orchards for sure
okay well you know it would be great if
we could find some money too
definitely
all right craig uh we'll be in touch
about that thanks
okay uh david let's go ahead with your
presentation
okay
thank you very much
all right so i wanted to start just to
address some of the chat questions a
little bit if you go to http colon slash
laser
scarecrow
that will redirect you over to this
google page
and from there if you click on the 2020
design which we are no longer providing
but some of you have
you will be able to access for example
the
user manual
and
is that
when i clicked on that did that open a
new window and no longer be what's
shared i think
um
let me
i i believe so it looks like what you're
trying to do yeah uh let me see if i can
nope it i'll have to
tell it to share that anyway if you
i'll switch to the pdf i had opened
uh
that opens the pdf and
you know to answer one of the questions
right here under laser specifications
is where we provide the information from
which we calculated for you that nominal
ocular hazard distance
um
yeah it doesn't mean that the beam is
perfectly safe beyond that distance but
within this distance you should take
extra care
and there are numerous cautions and
advice provided here in the manual and
you will find similar text
in the instructions from other
devices that you might be able to obtain
so
so that's what we know about
laser safety it is certainly a concern
we
believe that we have designed the device
to comply
with the
required
fd in the us fda has responsibility for
it for lasers as a source of radiation
that can affect health
and so we believe that our design is in
compliance with those
regulations
and
you know file our paperwork and get our
accession number
so let me
switch over to
what the main idea was
[Music]
all right wanting to talk about
the
design improvements and i'll try to make
this understandable for people who
haven't worked with the previous designs
also and try to put some of these issues
in context for you
uh come on
i presume somebody would have told me if
that were these slides weren't visible
so
a little bit of history on the
scarecrow project my involvement started
as a helpful faculty spouse when rebecca
said hey you've been playing around with
these arduino things
do you think you can come up with a way
of wiggling a laser around a
field
know first design was quite
crude uh plywood everything kind of
nailed or hot glued onto a plywood base
with a
chain drive and um
is kind of kind of messy but we got the
idea across
after a couple of years we were able to
upgrade that to a belt drive and circuit
board
had a little bit of trouble selecting
the 3d printed material the first one we
did kind of melted thus the need for the
reinforcing wood blocks here well it
didn't melt but softened
2020 i think was a really substantial
improvement in that we found a slip ring
where we could put a drive shaft
straight through it and not deal with
either a belt or a chain
we're continuing that idea in
2022
with the current design the major
changes are that we no longer have that
plywood base i had this idea i i was
basically having trouble
fitting some extra components we needed
on the circuit board
around the motor stand
and suddenly had this idea well what if
we just had the
circuit board go around the motor stand
and so now we have a circular circuit
board
uh the motor main board slip ring holder
all mount to that bucket bottom with
just four screws
um
the
pinball tilt switch had been giving us a
little bit of a trouble and so we've
moved that to a tinier sensor on the
main board
and no longer having a plywood base just
to that key switch that is required by
fda
is moved to the motor mount
not shown are the external controls
and you may notice that compared to the
previous
design based on a five gallon bucket
this is based on a three and a half
gallon bucket
and so you know
it's a little bit shorter reduces the
wind load
we went back to a white bucket with
black tape partly because white buckets
are what we could find and
the the black tape versus the aluminum
is a little easier to obtain
but also we're looking we've had some
difficulty with the tape sensor not
being reliable you go from about two lux
at dawn
to 40 or 50 000 lux in full sun
and it's just really difficult for the
tape sensor to
maintain accuracy
through that range of ambient light
and so we're planning i'm working on the
software that will just kind of map out
the
range of rotation
at power on and then use an extra magnet
and magnet sensor to help track the
rotation
so those are some of the big changes
many potential areas of
improvement were suggested by growers
and fellow researchers such as
as chuck and julie
um
and i have organized the rest of the
slides to kind of go at what the ones
that i think are most relevant and most
interesting uh and working on down
so one of the
challenges with operating the 2020 and
earlier designs are that everything is
basically on that one main circuit board
which is inside the bucket under a very
tight gasketed lid and on the top of
your 10-foot pole
so that makes control changes
rather awkward
there are also some
slight confusion with using the software
having to wait 15 seconds before it
saves the changes
so
in 2022 um
these little waterproof boxes are
surprisingly expensive but some other
cost savings help make it possible
we've got that
at the end of a 15 foot cable
so you should be able to just stick that
down on the bottom of the pole
there's a push button on it so it knows
when you're trying to make changes and
then it'll just save the changes when
you switch it off so that should be a
lot easier
in this one
okay
i mentioned that we've had some trouble
with the tape sensor
and
so one couple changes we've made have
found a sensor that is better optimized
for longer distances
there are still some divisive device
variation and it seems to lose about 20
percent of its sense range
between
a dark room versus
full 40 000 lux sun which is what we got
on a nice day recently
but for i'm happy to say that despite
that i still have a nice gap between the
reflectance of the white bucket and the
black tape where they we should always
be able to tell the difference
but just in case we can't
we've got this little magnet will be
mounted along with the tape sensor
and this
magnet sensor will be mounted inside the
bottom bucket at a fixed position
so that wherever you put the tape it can
map that out initially
and then it just counts how many steps
it's taken with the motor to know its
position and just in case it gets bumped
or blown around by the wind or something
every once in a while it will also
double check its position against that
magnet
so that
hope that that will be working
reliably still have to finish the
software on that
hey dave um
can you explain what the tape sensor is
for oh right yeah thank you
um the i
the
tape sensor it allows you to mark an
area that the scarecrow should skip
so for example if you need to
put the scarecrow at the side of the
field maybe because the field's right up
against a road you might
block off
by marking the inside of the bucket with
tape
and the tape sensor would see that and
say oh i should shut down the laser and
skip rapidly over this area to get back
to somewhere i can be useful
uh that cover that well enough julie
um
uh yeah perfect thanks
thank you yes uh
so
rebecca mentioned that we have ours
designed not to work at night uh at
least once it's truly dark
we've had some trouble we've been using
just a standard cadmium sulfide
photoresistor which has been you know
how light sensors have worked since
you know forever
but they're this these do seem to be
inconsistent from part to part
if you have one that won't turn on
rapidly i can talk to you about putting
in an extra parallel resistor
to increase its sensitivity
still working on figuring out the
part-to-part consistency of a
replacement photo transistor
but this photo transistor has the
advantage in that it is specifically
designed for dawn dusk sensing
and uh that should offer some
improvements there
basically i've found that
um you know as soon as i get to like
about 10 lux it's almost at full level
and yeah
the 10 lux is nothing that's like you
can barely see where you're walking so
um another reliability issue is the
pinball tilt switch it works great for
telling you when something's
uh tilted over and this micro switch was
able to completely remove power to the
scarecrow
but we had a weird thing happen where
uh wind
a consistent wind could make the
scarecrow on the pole oscillate a little
bit
and at the right frequency that seemed
to actually make the pinball lift off
the switch and shut down the laser
even though it hadn't really been tilted
so
the replacement for that is just this
tiny little two millimeter square
ic on the main circuit board that is an
accelerometer
and what that does is it measures the
pull of gravity in
three directions
and so if we find that we've got less
than 0.9 g pulling down we know that the
scarecrow has tipped
over 45 degrees
and that would not happen in the light
wind so
the disadvantage being that's software
only it won't completely shut off power
but you know we can certainly turn off
the laser and stop the motor if we
detect that
uh
use of assembly and mounting in 2020 we
i was able to provide a you know cnc
pre-drilled
plywood base so that you could get all
your mounting holes in the right place
but still there were 16 of them and
some of them you can see the
accessing the screws for the main motor
here in the middle for a little
difficult we had to prove i provided a
custom tool for that
i think if you
assemble one of the 30 available 2022
kits you'll find that it is much simpler
we've got all these
uh
all these attachments have been replaced
with just four machine screws that go
into captive nylock nuts in the base of
the motor stand
so that's one of the things that having
that idea of putting the circuit board
around everything instead of off to the
side facilitated
a little bit of a challenge for some
people in getting the spiral arm
position it was easy to get it like too
far away and so it would lose a lot of
its range and not start pointing down
um
the there's there are some very slight
differences in geometry to try to help
ensure that you get the full range of
motion but perhaps one of the most
useful things will be just this little
hole in the side of the spiral arm
when you do your post assembly testing
and turn it on turn it off again
and the servo will have gone to this
midpoint position and then you can just
align that dot with the middle of the
laser module
this spiral iron pushes the laser down
to get the lower angles and then when it
comes up the laser points horizontally
so that should be easier to assemble
there
we had some trouble with a 3d printed
coupler
pandemic issues we're not able to get um
a good quality uh five millimeter
adapter so i printed one that worked
fine but you had to keep tightening it
because if you use loctite it crumbles
the plastic
we were able to find a good source of
aluminum couplers eventually and sent
those out so if you had a 20 20 kit
and you didn't get that upgraded yet you
should have received those parts and
can do that if you had any trouble with
these screws coming out
a couple unlucky people
managed to
damage one of the uh
we start with 12 volts from your battery
reduce that to 5 volts for the
electronics and
also to four and a half volts for the
laser though honestly the laser would be
as happy with five
the way we were tackling the laser meant
that if you
put that butt converter in one position
off they were separate from the circuit
board little daughter boards that you
plugged in
if you were off by one pin you could
damage the converter board and
microcontroller would and so
we've just totally bypassed those
separate
power modules instead we have one shared
power module that is
designed right into the main circular
board
oh and i also threw in a couple of fuses
uh right on little
resettable fuses right on the circuit
board so that should help make sure that
nothing goes too weird
uh one of the challenges with that lid
and accessing the controls is the
strength of the gasket you can see how
these corners really pull right over
where the bucket lid would be
we've found a vendor that
has an easy peel lid that goes with
their buckets
that seems to be enough we're not trying
to keep liquid from escaping the bucket
we just want rain to go somewhere else
and we had a couple heavy rainstorms did
not receive any
water coming in
certainly if you're more comfortable
with the gasketed lid given that you no
longer have to access the interior
controls you could
grab one of those at the hardware store
but this easy peel lid is what we'll be
providing
in the kits
for 2022.
a little bit of ease of use uh the
scarecrow itself is mounted if you if
you follow our uh model of mounting it
to a half inch
uh i'm sorry one inch half inch half
inch iron pipe
uh
we have the uh pipe hanger couple of
screws and
that's how the laser scarecrow holds
itself onto the pipe with a little brace
we use the same pipe hanger to mount the
emergency stop switch box
well now we've also got a box for the
external controls and it's like six
screws that's starting to sound a little
bit annoying
i found these spring clamps that we'll
use instead they'll be on the back of
these little pieces of pvc trim that
hold the boxes and you should be able to
just snap those by pushing them onto the
pole
or pulling them off and that should make
things a little bit easier there
added a piezo buzzer to provide a
warning tone that will
provide some
feedback on well perhaps most
importantly the pre-laser warning tone
where
in 2020 we don't have a buzzer so
instead we just spin the arm around
rapidly a few times
as your pre-emission warning
uh we'll probably still do that but also
uh have the
buzzer going there too
we'll also be able to use that to
indicate error modes
uh that for example if you've said we
really need to make sure we see the tape
here but it can't sense the tape for
some reason
uh or fails to home
uh then we could indicate that with a
tone
yeah
unfortunately i can't get the pitch low
enough to make it sound like it's
snoring when it's asleep but we'll maybe
make it click every once in a while
julie's video showed laser barriers hers
were
seemed to be a little bit translucent
green which was sufficient to lower the
intensity i think and diffuse the beam
to make it easier to set that up
we've found that
uh black poly report covers that you can
get at copy shops office supply shops
and we'll include one with the kits
seem to work really well you can cut
them to size shape and they're stiff
enough to just slide it in between the
outer bucket and the inner bucket
and do a fine job of blocking the laser
not showing right here
you see this is the uh tape sensor and
so what you'd want it you you would also
put some black tape around here
if you were actually trying to block
this area and that would instruct the
laser
this the circuitry to skip that area
uh we're planning to also take a just a
common deburring tool and peel off a
little bevel from the outside of the
inner bucket and the inside of the outer
bucket just to make that easier for you
to slide that in and so if you like this
idea and have a 20 20 design or earlier
that's how we make the little bevel and
you should be able to do that pretty
easily if you don't have one of those
tools there already they're fairly
inexpensive
um
we the design for the laser attenuator
the cap
there's this little ring at the end of
the laser that these ridges would hook
onto in 2020
i
wanted something well i've never seen
that they actually fall off it just
seemed a little imprecise and
with the addition of this o-ring around
the end of the laser you can now kind of
screw that on
and that should that will hold
even more securely than the previous
version
useful for transport and if you're
setting it up and stuff like that
one thing that was confusing is
sometimes people go out to their field
and look at the laser and hey it's not
doing anything and it turns okay i turn
it off and back on and it's fine again
i think what we were seeing was that
based on the manufacturer
recommendations we were asking letting
the laser cool down for five minutes
every 30 minutes because they
recommended a duty cycle of two to four
hours which is nothing compared to a
summer day
um
i did some testing and found that while
the laser module would heat rapidly in
the first couple of hours
it after about it didn't continue to
heat
it went from an ambient temperature of
about 22 to somewhere around 30 and just
stayed there a little bit colder
overnight
um
you know furnace came on in the morning
i think
uh
and
oh then that big drop is where i
accidentally knocked it over and decided
that was the end of the test but uh
anyway
the laser seemed fine it didn't seem to
have any trouble
living at 30 degrees centigrade instead
of 25 and so we're not including that
cooldown anymore in 2022.
um
couple people had trouble with the
crimp terminals pulling off the
wiring for the emergency stop switch
uh we're going to
um
hired a student with greater hand
strength to do the crimping and also are
using marine style crimps with heat
shrink and a waterproof wire nut for the
ones that just go together instead of uh
having spade
tongue terminals on that
um
a little bit of uh
pot
when you when you put our scarecrow
show it here um
the
i was just in this is really minor but
if we're going to try to keep things
straight and level it seem like we ought
to try to fit the pipe better here's
that half inch iron pipe into the one
inch pvc
so i made a little shim to take up that
extra space and also spent some time
calculating the taper
of the bucket much more precisely and so
we have a thicker pad on the bottom and
a thinner pad on the outside
it honestly probably doesn't make a big
difference i mean your pole isn't
necessarily straight anyway but
it might help a bit
minor assembly issue is that you have to
be careful of the shaft when
assembling it because the shaft you can
see the end of the shaft was just a
little too long and you wouldn't want to
bend that i've shorted the shaft a
little bit so now you can just put the
bucket bottom on a flat surface and push
the bucket top straight down onto it
also makes it easier to stack multiple
units if you do
have that
so those are the major changes that
we've made for the
design in 2022
um well it's probably too late to make
further changes to the kit design but if
they're you know
we definitely want to know if you
experience issues or
failures
using the device anything i haven't
mentioned please do let me know um
so you know i as of right now i don't i
think rebecca has said this is the last
year of the grants we currently have so
future development isn't certain but
knowing what can be improved is always
useful
i think thanks so much david um
and um
i'm going to have chuck bourne go next
with some of his tips as we're about 10
15
so as he's preparing to share his slides
david could you
address how long do you think it takes
to assemble one of the new kits roughly
and
again the cost and how to get
one of the kits and then any other
questions you might address in the chat
itself
right um one question was
whether
you can
apply any of these upgrades
most of the upgrades do require a
different microcontroller and different
software
one grower has indicated an interest in
upgrading two of the kits i have about
five test boards that i might be able to
do with
with
do upgrades with
um
so
um
you know i'll i'll start to be talking
with that grower
still need to work on the details of
this first assembly time i think it was
it should be faster than the 2020 kits
i would
ex
i haven't been able to do one from start
to finish myself yet
but i'm thinking it's probably about
four hours
um you know depending on your
comfort level you know you can
take a look at the assembly instructions
from
2020 on that website and we'll try to
provide similar quality
this year
and the cost we are
going to
um
yeah so as rebecca said that 2018 kits
cannot easily be upgraded there are
because of the circuit board being
completely new um but
you know
the drive mechanism is the same and the
slip ring is the same so it's not
completely impossible either
uh not my current focus
and your last question was the cost i
think rebecca mentioned that we are
trying to let these kits out the door at
very close to our cost and
expecting that to be 650 dollars
okay great and so if people are
interested they can email
you and rebecca maybe rebecca can put
that email in the chat again
and we can certainly address that at the
end
so uh we're gonna move on with uh
chuck's
short presentation
um david if you want to address any of
those
uh chat questions you may certainly do
that in the chat thank you
so go ahead chuck bourne
thank you julie good morning everyone
hopefully you can hear me okay
so uh i'm just gonna talk a little bit
about how we mount our lasers because
that's one of the questions that i seem
to get quite a bit
uh there's no
i don't think easy way to do it and this
is just how we you know decided to do
ours i've seen other ways and i think
julie has a really cool way
that she developed for mounting hers
but i just want to run through some of
the general components and and why we
use this but
so
you know we just make a simple cross
with some treated uh two by fours uh and
then
go ahead and mount that floor flange
that you see right here and then we went
ahead and bought a 10 foot length of
half inch
threaded iron pipe that i cut in half
and then just screwed in so that's kind
of our base
right there
as you can see it goes up that's again
five feet
i also have you'll see these two pieces
of 3 8
rebar
we also used long bolts we had a bunch
of different ways
but these are essentially what we use to
pound into the ground to keep that that
base from moving
uh and we had pretty good pretty good
success with that you don't have to
plunk obviously you don't put them in
two foot
but just get them in enough so that that
base doesn't doesn't want to walk or
you know
move move on you
all right
and then just moving on uh so
the upper half of our unit um because i
had
already purchased and had uh some
uh half inch electrical conduit
uh that's what we
mounted the actual bracket that holds
the bucket
too
and what that allows me to do is i can
then take the electrical conduit pretty
much
put it side by side to the electrical
pipe and then
i use two
heavy duty hose clamps and i just
tighten those down
and that allows me to
i can adjust that height anywhere i want
to uh which is is really nice
um
it's a little cumbersome uh you can do
it by yourself you just got to make sure
you have a a good socket wrench with the
the socket with with the right socket
uh usually what i can do is i can
unloosen one of these
um get enough uh loosen this one a
little bit slide it to where i think
it's got to be and then tighten it right
back down so it's pretty pretty quick uh
also pretty inexpensive which is another
thing i'm all about trying to fuse what
i had around the house
so that's what we did
now we also added a
a solar charger uh trickle charger so
that
we you know don't have to keep swapping
out batteries uh and this the one that
we purchased was a 45 dollar unit off of
amazon
um it's a 20 watt uh 12 volt 10 amp
mono crystalline waterproof solar panel
and essentially
they don't give you anything to mount
those panels with
so i just went ahead and i
had some of these l brackets
and
just a simple pipe clamp
two of these one on the bottom one on
the top
um
one's a little bit longer than the other
just to get a little bit of an angle to
it
but but that worked out really good
and we could move that
unit around pretty quickly
so that's you know that's essentially
what my unit looks like in the field
top to bottom it's also nice to put that
battery up off the ground but it also
gives some weight on that base to keep
it from uh from floating or moving that
much
i will still say that the battery is
probably still the hardest part to move
it's the heaviest
i've been able to walk this thing into
the field um by myself with the battery
the scarecrow unit the base and uh you
know a two or three pound sledgehammer
to pound those uh rebar uh pieces in
uh so you can do it by yourself
um
i i guess this is just a really short
video but um
one of the things that we've noticed
is the fact that even a little bit of
breeze and you'll see the breeze kick up
here in a second
and david alluded to this earlier
with the tilt switch that was in there i
think that little bit of wiggle was
bouncing that ball in there and we kept
having the unit turn on and off
with the new the new changes this year
you know hopefully that's not going to
be an issue
um moving forward
we actually um and i think it might have
been on david's recommendation took a
piece of uh foam
like off of pool noodle or something i
had and stuck in the
in the where the pinball is in that tilt
switch
just to try to to limit the movement
um
you know i'm not sure
you know more rigid and and i think
julie uses a t-post which might be a
little more rigid but then takes a
little more effort to get in and out of
the field i think too
um but that's essentially as i said how
we uh have set ours up
um and then i i need to point this out
because i spent probably about an hour
and a half one day
on the cables that come david puts a
little piece of red tape on the positive
uh
wire cable
well somewhere along the lines that
slipped off and i lost it um and then i
have to follow all that cable back to
figure out um which one is the positive
and which one was the negative
and uh so go ahead and putting some
alligator clips on those instead of just
the bare wire um would probably help
uh or just making sure that you you
you know keep that uh
that wire that red wire on there to make
sure you always know what is your
positive and what your your
you could probably also just stick a
piece of black tape on the on the um
negative terminal
uh negative wire too and that would
would kind of clear that up a little bit
um and just you know the things that we
found and and we've been working with
these units since 2017
and
i will say that you know as far as
efficacy i do feel they work very well i
think it's another tool to add to our
tool box
but like anything else there's these
little caveats and and rebecca alluded
to it earlier you got to get them out
there early
before those scout birds are actually
out looking
because if they if you can keep them out
uh i think you'll do a much better job
of keeping the rest of the flock out
so i like to i try to get it out there
just as silking starts or midway through
soaking or even at the very tail end of
soaking
you cannot set it and forget about it
you need to go out and check on it once
in a while make sure they're working
make sure the battery is charged or
charging
so it's
it's still you know a little bit of time
that you need to spend to just make sure
that you're they're running properly
um
i
everything that we've done 90 of what
we've done there's been some other
deterrent uh in the field and in this
case we've been using it with propane
cannons so we have a laser maybe on one
end and a cannon on the other end
and i think that just keeps those birds
on edge enough because they don't know
what's coming they don't know if it's
the light they don't know if it's a
scare and then if you can back that up
there with a uh a shotgun blast every
once in a while um and i know that's
hard to do in
in places where uh you have neighbors
uh but it's it just reinforces that
whole idea and keeps them on their on
their toes
um and again you know
these units really the the uri units
have been great and
they're they're low cost enough where i
think you can have a couple units um and
you need to have a couple especially in
in fields where you have multiple
plantings uh so that you can kind of
keep moving them along
along the line
so those are the tips that i had
there's my contact information
um i you know
natasha and i uh our technician
i will say that we got pretty good at
assembling these units um and i think we
had it down this would be two of us
working on them
um we had it down to about an hour a
unit um which i thought was pretty good
um and uh i
i will offer my assistance uh wherever i
can at least for our region uh for those
of you that might want to try one or are
interested in purchasing one so with
that julie that's that's really all i
had to
to share
uh thanks so much chuck and um
so we're getting
uh just about out of time here i just
want to
show a couple things about my
setup
and so i'm gonna skip through that a
little bit
let me make sure i'm doing a slide show
okay yep
sometimes these uh
things so
okay uh just quickly this is how the
kits came to us last year i worked on
assembling them i had fun doing it but i
wasn't the quickest person uh really
well
um
really
really great kids that are really well
organized great directions
um
i wanted to just emphasize one thing is
say this is last year's kit and that is
make sure before you go to the field you
understand
how to
control the kits how they work that they
actually are working
um the last year's kits have a speed an
angle that
controls the tilt of the
laser and then what was called a wiggle
that
can allow for motion
in the vertical and of course david has
changed this but it took a lot for me to
understand how to
um
to
operate all this what they did and let
me tell you to go out in the field and
try to do it the first time was not a
good system for me i think i made almost
all of the mistakes that everybody else
talked about but in the end i i really
understand how they work
and um
and i think that that's a good thing for
success so again i had it in my office
and i was
able to test it out so either if you
have a battery or david supplied me with
an electrical cord that i could plug in
in my office and that worked out great
again
to make sure with the this laser had a
cap on it and you could watch it spin
around or the one on the right i had
just shining on the wall again please be
careful to protect your eyes if you're
doing this
okay set up uh in the field rebecca
already showed you this i was working in
very large processing sweet corn fields
in western new york uh my setup so i had
on the left i had a very uh sturdy
uh post that i got from our local
lowe's department store
these were the heaviest duty ones you
could i pounded those in the ground and
then i had to have something some kind
of post that i could
transport in my sedan car
and i came up with these telescopic
poles that are used for like the pool
industry where you could attach your
different uh net or whatever and then
scope them out uh 10 12 feet into a pool
to scope scoop up bugs or whatnot
i wanted to make um
the point that these posts at the bottom
had some holes drilled through and i
actually bolted those onto my steel post
that didn't go all the way into the
ground because i couldn't get it pounded
in but they were pretty sturdy this
particular setup i also
put another post next to it and kind of
um
tied everything together with duct tape
and little
straps and things like that i didn't go
with that later on and then you can see
i chose
a smaller size battery these are still
12 volt they're something that would be
used in like a golf cart or a scooter
they're 23 pounds there was no way in
heck i was able to lift a 50 60 pound
battery like chuck was doing
and um
that was how i managed uh the the
advantage of the telescopic pole it was
very easy to unscrew these
two
sections and slide them up and down
really easy
so here's a little better this one again
was where i had the two posts they were
kind of duct taped together
i had actually ended up having the on
off switch up more at user height which
made it really
easy but here's how you know you
basically unscrew these two different
things or loosen them up and then you
can adjust the height of the laser i
spent a lot of time trying to get the
laser height
right
then in the end we were collecting data
and
we had a 10-foot
pvc pipe or later on i actually did have
a measuring tape out there and we were
collecting how many of the ears in that
10-foot section had bird damaged bird
peck
um i also want to just show two of my
grower setups this was one grower we
were working with
in niagara county he had a 10 foot
pole and again he had it kind of he
pounded in a t post and connected this
laser to that it was pretty sturdy
but i also wanted to point out he had
scary balloons on this grower i think he
had the laser too high up in the air but
the grower was pretty happy in reduction
in the number of flights the last
slide i'm going to show this is another
grower we had down in chautauqua county
he mounted his black iron pipe onto this
tote
that has the wire gridding on the
outside so he had it permanently mounted
to that again i think he's got it too
high up in the field but he was able to
move that tote around with a forklift or
tractor or whatnot in his field and you
can see he's got aisles or row laneways
down his sweet corn fields and was able
to move it around
and then on the right hand side he was
also using these uh air dancers which he
was actually fairly happy with and they
were uh powered by a a little generator
he had a series of four or five of them
down his laneway so i'm going to end
that
presentation
and stop sharing that so we are a little
bit over our time
i would like so anyone that wants to
jump off go ahead i'll leave the chat
and the presentation open if anyone
wants to hang on
for more discussions so apologize that
we ran over a little bit obviously we
have a lot of experience to share
but we really hope if you are interested
in
or obtain the scarecrows that
you know we're there to support you
and
continue to have questions and what we
really want to make sure is that you
have
success so if you have any questions
please contact us
either now or
at the end or
during the season
all right thank you very much
again i'll i'll leave it open if anyone
wants to unmute or
put more questions in the chat box
and another question
about how do we order those laser
scarecrow kits
maybe rebecca or david want to unmute
and just address that
yeah the uh email brownweb
uri.edu
uh that's
dr rebecca brown um
[Music]
and she put her email in the chat box
also great and but i would also mention
that uri is not interested in us just
selling kits when you request a kit from
us
you are
paying for the parts and also agreeing
to participate in the research we are
allowed to
distribute the kits as part of dr
brown's research program and we'll ask
you
to contribute your observations from the
field to that research
and uh david when can you address when
you think the kits are going to be
available
i
am hoping for
uh
our semester and last day of classes is
may 2nd and i hope to be have have those
kits available
right around then
i
unfortunately
need to be able to finish the user
manual and
to in order to send that to fda as part
of our application for that a session
number before we can release it and
then
uh
you know having the user manual done
means having the software done and
yeah and all the kits design well anyway
but yeah i'm hoping to be able to finish
that up in another month or so okay
uh perfect yeah thanks for addressing
that um i've been incredibly impressed
of how much
thought has gone into these laser
scarecrows and and truly how much
testing
and just realized that uh to get to this
point
you know there was a lot of work and so
again
we
we are pretty confident that laser
scarecrows as rebecca
presented
do work against birds
but we're trying to iron out a lot of
the details and
the feedback that came in last year
after a number of growers had these out
in the field really informed this design
and you could see all of the changes
that that took place for the 2022
units so really looking forward to
testing those out
in the field
so appreciate that
i just want to jump on and thank julie
for organizing this whole thing
uh yep you're very welcome
um
michael has asked a couple of times
about
any evidence anecdotal or otherwise of
lasers working with mammals i believe
the answer is that there is anecdotal
evidence that it does not work
there's actually studies that it does
not that lasers do not work with deer
with deer species yes specifically okay
i guess we could ask i'm thinking like
what other mammals might there be so
raccoons are
right a problem but as you said uh they
tend to come in at night i believe so
the units that we have turn off at night
so the light sensor
uh when it gets you know to dusk or dark
will turn the units off and then they
will be turned back on
um
at dawn
um because they are designed for
you know the scaring the birds away
so yeah and david was thinking about
voles also so
yeah i i don't i don't think that's
going to it could volts mostly do their
damage at night don't they rebecca
um
various times they'll do it during the
day too but i really given how low they
are to the ground i don't think they
would care about a laser i really wish
they worked with bowls but
yeah i also thought voles had poor
eyesight
they probably do
i mean they see better than moles do but
i don't think they have great eyesight
um quebec asked if fields are surrounded
by houses does this present a safety
concern yes absolutely anytime
you're using a laser near humans you
need to be concerned about safety
one of the things you can do is mount
the laser high and aim it down you can
also set up the
tape and barrier system to exclude the
areas of houses uh you know if it's like
on one side
uh or you know a house here and a house
there but
i mean if you've got like a community
garden plot surrounded by houses this is
probably not a good uh
pest control approach lasers you know if
they're if you just can't
you know get it around humans so
yeah that's that's a good point uh david
so i i didn't get into my setup but one
of my
uh big processing fields that i had last
year
um even though the field
you know i would have called the field
mostly flat i didn't realize that
where i entered the field was sort of
like a dip and there was a road there
and so as i was driving towards the
field over the road one time
i saw the flash of that laser and i
scared the heck out of me i'm like and
there were houses
kind of on the other side of the road
i'm like oh i can't have this so i
did two things one is i put the laser
down a little bit further into the corn
canopy and then that was where i also
had that
green plastic barrier and that was
enough
to
you know eliminate that flash but i
spent a lot of time looking
at what was going on in that field and i
also
again if you can go out there either on
a really cloudy day or preferably at
dusk you'll see what's what's happening
and so you know at dusk if the laser is
turning off you can just shine a
flashlight on the light center
and that'll make it you know run
[Music]
and
yeah i was really concerned about that
so i think that you just have to be
aware and look at your setup if you're
not on a really
flat surface again trying to be at the
top of the hill
pointing it down it's it's so
that road was a good a thousand feet
away from my laser setup and i was
thinking oh you're only going to be able
to see this like for 300 feet or
something but not that it was gonna
damage anybody's eyes or anything out
that far but i could see the flash and i
was kind of worried if one of the houses
you know they see me going in and out of
the field could probably see that unit
i'm like this is not good i never had
any complaints from the farmer or the
people but i was really really cautious
about that
and then again it looks like in the chat
we're just talking about trying to get
those uh the laser beam and sweet corn
um across the top of those tassels so
there's if you're too high right there's
a possibility of
the birds flying underneath the beam
yep so that's that's that's
something to consider
and i guess i just say you know go out
there see what the birds are doing does
it look like they're deterring hopefully
you know hopefully we're
scaring them away from your sweet corn
fields and that there's something else
for them to eat somewhere else and they
just it's too much of a
headache to be in the sweet corn but boy
once they get the taste of that sweet
corn then it's pretty hard to uh to stop
them
so anybody have experience with finch or
chickadee size birds and blueberries i
would have to say i don't know rebecca's
answer i i would say i had uh
some uh
uh
goldfinch right i think that's what
their name is you know the little yellow
ones in the summer that come around eat
the thistles and stuff goldfinches right
eastern goldfinch i'm the name is
escaping me but they didn't seem to be
bothered if they were sitting on the
the tassels they didn't seem to be
bothered by the presence of the lasers
or actually even my presence so
anyway any experience with
other birds
we haven't really tested it on finches
and chickadees i
have observed that sparrows are not
impressed by lasers
um they will
ignore them
um
in general what i've seen in blueberries
again is that the birds that tend to
feed in very small flocks or
individually
are a lot less
affected by the lasers
than the ones that feed in larger flocks
all right thanks rebecca so i think
looking at the time i need to let my
presenters uh you know off the hook here
so
i'm going to go ahead and close the
meeting
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu